what's going on guys this is Rob and I
imagine a lot of people who are not
familiar with Marvel Comics saw the
trailer for x-men Days of Future past
and when they saw Peter Dinklage they
couldn't help but scratch their heads
and ask the question who the hell is
that guy playing so in an effort to
shine some light on this we are going to
have a discussion about ball of our
trash and at the end of this video I
want to have somewhat of an in-depth
philosophical discussion about him
because he's one of my favorite
characters of Marvel Comics not because
of what he does but because of his
reason behind it so ball of our Trask of
course was a human and he was an
anthropologist meaning that he studied
human beings both past and present
he studied cultures societies arts all
different kinds of things anything that
had to do with the progress of humanity
his belief system was that a time would
come when mutants would eventually wage
war against humans it may be one mutant
who starts it it may be that all the
mutants wage war but the fact remains
that unless something is done then
humans are going to be at the mercy of
mutants simply because they don't really
stand a chance against the upper echelon
characters in the Marvel Universe this
was kind of compounded by the fact that
he had two children both of which were
mutants the first was Larry Trask and
Larry Trask was a precognitive meaning
that he could see into the future he was
very very powerful so it was very rare
that he was ever wrong for example he
looked into the future and saw the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelley
that would lead into the Days of Future
past storyline his second child was
Tanya Trask I think her name was Tanya
and she was a time traveler but she was
actually lost in the timestream and
ended up in the 39th century where she
became madam sanctity under the eye of
Rachel summers now eventually she tries
to jump back into the past and stop her
father seminal program but Rachel Sommer
stops her but as Bolivar Trask doesn't
necessarily see the psychic battle that
goes on ultimately this kind of
reinforces the idea along with his sons
reinforcement of this idea that mutants
are inherently dangerous and of course
bear in mind that at this point his son
doesn't realize that he has any
I mean powers whatsoever now the
interesting thing to me is that the
Sentinel program was not initially
designed to be this oppressive group
over mutants the Sentinel program was
designed to be a protection for humans
against mutants the problem was that
almost as soon as the Sentinels were
created by ball of our Trask they
revolted and the logic of the Sentinels
kind of followed I'm kind of
paraphrasing here it followed in this
particular order
the Sentinels rationalized that they
were programmed to protect human beings
and therefore they were programmed to
protect human beings from the mutant
threat but sentinels themselves were
superior to mutants otherwise they would
not have been tasked with protecting
humans from them if the Sentinels are
superior to a mutant and mutants are
superior to humans then the symbols are
superior to both mutants and humans and
so sue sentinels began to sort of have
this collective consciousness which was
led by the entity master mold who was
this super Sentinel so to speak and they
kind of began to develop their own their
own strategies their own kind of plans
you know their own method of doing
things and they came quite dangerous
eventually they were disbanded they were
destroyed but they were brought back by
Larry Trask some time later in the
future now with regards to why Bolivar
Trask did what he did this is the kind
of thing that I love to discuss it's
really kind of what I like to get into
because the question that you really
have to ask here is is ball of our Trask
wrong for having his belief system is he
wrong to believe that a time will come
when a mutant somewhere will become so
incredibly powerful that he may even
unwillingly or unwittingly pose a threat
to humanity and possibly even obliterate
humanity or that a mutant will come
along that's so powerful that they will
wage a war against humanity because they
will view humanity as being obsolete I
mean there were several several
instances in the Marvel comics where all
of our Trask would sit down and I think
he actually agreed to a debate on mutant
human relations with Xavier but his mind
wasn't changed and to me I understood
that because Xavier does not speak for
all of mutant kind
Xavier speaks for those with like minds
but Xavier does not speak for Magneto
for example he doesn't speak for
apocalypse mr. sinister he doesn't speak
for these guys they had their own
agendas they are on their own plans
which they intend to implement at every
possible term as an anthropologist and a
person who studies the history of
humanity
I highly doubt there's really been any
instances where ball of our Trask has
read on an example of a more advanced
society encountering a less advanced
society and the two of them being able
to coexist amicably in virtually every
instance where a more advanced society
has encountered a less advanced society
is involved the extermination of the
less advanced society Christopher
Columbus and the citizenry of San
Salvador English separatists and Native
Americans English citizens and the
expansion and their expansion into
Africa and West African territories
these are all instances where the entire
groups of less advanced people were
eliminated or they were folded into the
more advanced society but suffice it to
say the less advanced society as was
discovered ceased to exist if there's
any one thing that I agree with its the
ideology that people exist to pass on
their genes that people exist to try to
survive and so to me much like our
discussion with the character Galactus
to say the ball of our Trask is wrong is
to say that he's wrong for simply trying
to survive now I'm not saying his
methods are good I'm not saying that you
know creating these giant robots
designed to effectively obliterate
mutants was a great idea not at all but
I am saying that his rationale behind
his belief system and why he views the
supposed threat of mutant kind the way
he does is very justifiable because at
the end of the day mutants are humans
and mutants are subject to the same
prejudices as humans they're subject to
the same desires physical emotional
spiritual as human beings are is the
reason why we have mutant villains who
just simply want to get money we have
mutant villains who want to acquire
physical pleasure and there are mutant
villains who want to acquire emotional
pleasure for example a character like
graviton
when he first discovered his ability to
manipulate gravity he relished in the
fact that he was able to terrify people
with it so at the end of the day I think
the important thing to bear in mind here
is that when it comes to a character
like ball of our Trask he's complicated
he's interesting
but his viewpoints aren't extreme and I
wouldn't necessarily categorize them as
wrong because he is a human being
encountering a more advanced city or
more advanced civilization and it's
fearful of his own extermination so with
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace